&gt;&gt; We know that in order to graph these two curves, we simply set y equal to
each side of the equation that we originally started with. So the two lines that
we have are this orange one, whose equation is y equals 3x squared plus 7x minus
10, and this black one whose equation is y equals 2x squared plus 5x plus 5. Now
these points of intersection are points that lie on both of these curves. So
that means the coordinates these points satisfy each of these equations. We
already know the x coordinates of each point so all we need to do now to figure
out the corresponding y coordinates is to pick either of these equations and
plug in each x coordinate. So I'm kind of feeling this one right here. Doesn't
matter which one you choose though. You'll get the same answer regardless of
which equation you pick. So starting with this equation I'm going to plug in the
negative 5 to see what y value corresponds to that x value on both curves. When
I plug in x equals negative 5 I end up with y equals 30. So that means that the
coordinates of this point must be negative five comma 30. Now let's do the same
thing with x equal three, for this point. Solving for y when x equal three gives
us 38, so we have the point three comma 38 as our other point of intersection.